so how do you feel about having the
vaccine if it becomes available to you
too i don't think i'm scared of anything
if i had the opportunity i definitely
would go and get it
getting vaccinated against covid is
something the skinner family all have
opinions on both 15 year old bella and
her 13 year old brother henry would like
the jab what are your thoughts what the
pros and cons of having the vaccine
i think the benefits of getting this
will that mean that i can go into the
future in gcses without having to miss
school or
have anything affect my learning
dad carl believes parents should have
the choice when it comes to vaccinating
their children
i felt that the chances of them getting
covered were more detrimental
than the chances of them getting ill
from having the vaccine and looking at
previous the previous history of
vaccines and the current vaccine
indicated that there's no real risk
but the government's advisers the jcvi
don't think vaccinating all 12 to 15
year olds is necessary
in the information the jcvi says shows
marginal benefit to the health of a 12
to 15 year old making some parents
hesitant
looking at the
so far medical advice if they're saying
no then i think no i think it should
always be the parent's choice but it
should be discussed with the child
depending on age as well because of a
scientific thing that they're saying i
wouldn't allow them to get it at this
age you know they want to experiment on
the kids they shut all the schools down
and
it's not even affecting the children
instead they recommend only those with
underlying health conditions get the jab
they want more research into the rare
side effect of heart inflammation
while this may not be a straightforward
comms message
this is really about scientific honesty
and people do need to have the
information that they they would want in
order to decide what to do if the
vaccine is made available for these
children
in the information the jcvi says shows
marginal benefit to the health of a 12
to 15 year old the government though
want a broader perspective and has asked
chief medical officers to consider the
impact on wider society
one worry is that covert 19 could spread
when schools reopen further disrupting
education
if the government chooses not to
vaccinate children then it will be all
the more important that they have other
mitigations in place or we're going to
see a really disrupted term families
won't have long to sit around and wait
for a decision the government said to be
hopeful that vaccines will be offered to
all 12 to 15 year olds and will make an
announcement within days charlotte lomas
sky news